chichi gonzalez his best work has been
like everyone else in the rotation at
coors field yeah 362 era early
opportunity here for christian yelich
yelling shits one on the ground there's
story flips to rogers for one that's all
they'll get is wong is home first out of
the game first run of the game brewers
again as they did last night
runs on the board in the opening inning
put the ball in play christian hustling
down the line not hit hard enough for
the double play and the brewer is on the
board early once again
2-2 swung on it miss so chichi gets a
strikeout for the second out
two men out yelling at second darvaya's
at first and derrick fisher in the
lineup today in right field he's at the
plate it's always been good to hit at
coors field
fischer agrees there's a base head into
left field yelich rounding third and
it's a two run first here for the crew
rbi single for derrick fisher one and
two
[Music]
well tough first inning for chichi as
the brewers get two runs on four singles
the left-hander eric lauer yeah eric one
and three so far the earned run out a
little bit over five
he gets a strikeout of trevor's story
into the count the blackman two men out
of the first and that is a called third
strike and that's a heck of a pitch
lachman didn't like it
that looked like it hit the zone just
clipped the edge nice work by lauer
getting back-to-back strikeouts rocky's
strand to runner two-nothing brewers
after one
here's colton wong who started the day
with a single to center field
going after the first pitch again and
this is hitting the air deep left field
tapia going back and that is out of here
a home run for colton wong and the
brewer is getting to gonzalez early on
this father's day afternoon
and this is in the right field the base
hit for dog
as we say if nothing else that will flip
the lineup over with two outs chi-chi
comes up
uh comebacker to lauer
the first couple innings have been a
problem well he has hung up a couple of
zeros here this afternoon they start for
the brewers after two innings of play
the ball two strikes to story
now we're looking for a one two three
inning and he'll get it another
strikeout there's four of them now
as we are through three innings lauer
and the brewers with a four-nothing lead
jackie bradley jr in scoring position
for colton wong he has wasted no time in
each of his first two at bats swinging
right away
and it continues and there's another
base hit into right field jbj rounding
third
and he will score as colton wong has
seen three pitches today single
two run homer
rbi single
and there's a ground ball snapped up by
adamus
and a one two three inning for eric
lowery
see if he can get a ground ball here
from narvaez he can this should be a two
uh he's a double play
how about that move there by uh joshua
fuentes
again we see so many variations now of
double plays the 71st that the rockies
have turned
there's a breaker ball that lands strike
three call
strikeout number five for eric lauer
fisher pulls a ball by a diving
c.j crone down into the corner fisher's
thinking three
throw to third is not in time
derrick fisher had not gotten a hit
in his first three appearances for the
brewers he's got two today
two strikes on her ear swung on it
missed
and there's one out
well it eric lauer will be
stepping to the plate you might see him
drop down another punt
nope going to try to lay it down and he
does coming home as fisher man putting
on a clinic on how you bunt today nicely
done eric lauer getting derrick fisher
home and it's a six nothing game
go to the bottom of the sixth inning and
the rockies are down six
el topia leading off here for the
rockies another 3-2
and back up
one base hit
17 straight games for rival tapia that's
his 33rd hit during this hit streak this
game has been one-sided but it's not out
of reach especially at coors field
position take a good look you won't see
it
trevor's story is struck out twice
against lauer
and this ball crushed to left field
it's been awhile
but story knows the round around the
bases his sixth of the year
here
trevor's story makes it 6-3 milwaukee
here's
left chrome field this one's gonna fly
rockies are within a run
three jacks in the end fuente's a
strikeout and a pop-out
[Applause]
and the game is tied at six
one away for daniel vogelback
with the 3-2 again
and volgo back with a base head into
right field here comes jace peterson
rounding third the throw to the plate
and safe at home is peterson as he gets
through nunez and then it's uncorked
into right field
moving his second the big fella and he's
out at second but the brewers take the
lead there are two outs in the inning
and a ground ball to the right side
so bard wins the battle with narvaez 14
pitch battle
and
the fist bump
between bard and omar and narvaez you
know what no matter how hard you compete
you know the mutual respect i love to
see that
so here comes story
story base hit
and here comes charlotte
02.
blackman ground ball fair game over jase
peterson makes the play
and the brewers find a way
to defeat the colorado rockies once
again